bees pollinate one third of the food
grown in the United States essential to
producing an estimated 15 billion
dollars worth of crops annually but bee
colonies are collapsing due to disease
parasites pesticides and even climate
change fueled droughts Annette kleiser
is CEO of dalon animal health which
partnered with the University of Georgia
to develop the world's first honeybee
vaccine how challenging was it to figure
out a vaccine for a bee it was very
challenging unlike humans and animals
insects don't create antibodies so
scientists have long thought vaccines
simply won't work but in the lab they
discovered bees have a primitive immune
system and exposing a queen bee to some
of the Dead bacteria through her food
created immunity in the hive